we have a voicemail number which is 2192
david p
here is yet another question about 2020
and donald trump hey david have a quick
question
theoretically brian wins now yes trump
spends the next four years building his
base even more could you run for
president
again and fulfill his second term four
years later
can you legally do that within the
constitution within our
laws i'm not sure yes you can so the
question is if trump loses now and
biden's president four years could trump
run in 2024 he could i don't think he
will i think if
listen if trump loses he is a narcissist
he will have to justify his loss he
can't just say i lost
i lost because people didn't want me i
lost because i messed up
trump will justify it and say i didn't
want it anyway
screw you guys i've got better things to
do etc
trump will be nearly 80 in 2024. trump
is not going to run in 2024 if he loses
this is it okay this is the opportunity
we can get trump out and that will be it
for donald trump now
don jr or eric or ivanka who the hell
knows that's another story we'll cross
that bridge when we come to it
but this is it if trump is not president
the next four years
that is it for trump's presidency we've
got a great bonus show for you today
so many great stories i hope you'll join
me on the bonus show
and remember that you can get instant
access to that world famous bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com